I do feel like it's what I imagined a
hard couple of months for you how are
you doing you know as long as kids will
be okay I'll be okay you know what I
mean that's that's the end all one day
at a time like what other cliches can I
throw on top of each other
Rachael Leigh Cook opening up to et
about her separation from hubby Daniel
Gillies the duo who share two children
five-year-old Charlotte and
four-year-old Theodore announced they
were splitting after 14 years of
marriage with identical Instagram posts
On June 13 I don't know what I'm doing
so if anybody has any advice seriously
tag me online I'm all yours I'm
listening you are like a shining star to
me like you were always the nicest
cutest and I think you just be you know
seriously like you're amazing do you
feel like this is kind of time for like
me time right now my kids are 4 & 5 so
like when it's me time somebody let me
know took an hour for myself and that
felt really good
it feels uncertain and nobody warns you
how hurdled ulting is gonna be I'm never
bored and I'm very grateful how are the
kids that's like a long story Daniels
actually filming in New Zealand for
almost three months now and so we can't
formally talk to him about what's going
on until he's back because otherwise
what it means is dad disappeared that's
far from anything that do you know
whatever do i or or myself he's
hopelessly devoted to them and like you
know we're gonna get through this
together
he's he's an amazing person I still
consider him my very best friend you
know we'll make it one way or another
the doors still open them the analogy I
like to use is the characters stay the
same but this chapter is ending we move
forward don't make it that much harder
that I have to be here asking you these
questions that it's happening in the
public because trust me it's not my
favorite thing that was like if you
weren't so nice I think it might have
been difficult but like someone give
this girl a raise that was like such as
like a sweet and lovely transition and
you're doing a great job totally respect
that this is good preparation for her
like how I'm going to talk to my kids
maybe this was a good stepping stone
into that apparently I'm in good company
it's it's LA
nobody the funniest part about this was
like nobody was not surprised that
almost surprised me the most ever it's
like what else done what what should we
have for dinner because I talked to you
guys together secret to the marriage and
he said being married to Rachel I'll
tell you the secret the secret is marry
Rachel that's the secret I take it very
personally usually but extra couples
crank up on my book we're probably next
not really they didn't think so then but
you know we got married when I was 24 I
think we're just a little bit ahead of
the curve so it feels like we're first
and that's hard
I don't know I still love him to death
he's gone and I miss him but we're just
gonna forge a new path forward in your
life forever you guys share kid
oh yeah he's not gotten rid of me that
easy and speaking of sweet the 39 year
old actress has been busy working on a
new Hallmark Channel Christmas movie
which she was promoting at the network's
2019 TCA press corps event on Friday
night the Christmas bride why does it
come in out what can you tell us I hope
before Christmas like I don't have any
say but I think this is a bookstore all
bookstores have coffee we don't have
coffee you've become such a staple in my
home around the holidays do you now feel
like a sense of like pressure people
coming up to you now more asking about
palm work than they do from your famous
amazing movies so let's just take people
who love them some hallmark they're not
shy about it and they love it so very
much as do i and they want a chat they
know that if you work with homework that
you're down like that you're your family
and that's the way I feel when I'm here
and
I'm excited to be doing a Christmas
movie because now it's like that's inner
circle time you know I was ready and now
it's like they put me in so just got to
deliver
[Music]
[Applause]